>>> AT THE TOP OF THE PROGRAM WE
TOLD YOU ABOUT A NEW ASSESSMENT
FROM A T HOMELAND SECURITY
OFFICIAL DESCRIBING THE THREAT
ENVIRONMENT AHEAD OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AS, QUOTE, INCREDIBLY
HEIGHTENED.
ALSO JUST IN, ARIZONA'S
SECRETARY OF STATE TONIGHT SAID
SHE SENT ADDITIONAL REPORTS OF
WHAT THEY CALL MULTIPLE --
EXCUSE ME -- POTENTIAL VOTER
INTIMIDATION TO THE STATE'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
THE FEDERAL JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, KATIE HOBBS,
IS THE DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR IN THE STATE.
IN ANY EVENT, THE NEW ALLEGED
INCIDENTS COME IN ADDITION TO
THE ONE THAT GOT SO MUCH
ATTENTION OVER THE WEEKEND.
CNN'S KYUNG LAH HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: OUTSIDE AN EARLY
BALLOT DROP BOX IN MESA,
ARIZONA, TWO MEN ARMED, WEARING
TACTICAL GEAR, WATCHING VOTERS.
A VIGIL TAKING PLACE OVER
MULTIPLE NIGHTS.
>> HI, GUYS.
>> Reporter: ONE WOMAN, A
PHOENIX-AREA GRANDMOTHER,
DECIDED TO CONFRONT THEM.
>> HEY!
>> Reporter: WHY DID YOU DECIDE
TO GO OUT THERE?
>> I'M STANDING UP AND PUSHING
BACK AGAINST THOSE PEOPLE AND
STANDING UP FOR EVERYBODY'S
RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> YOU DON'T MIND IF I SET UP
RIGHT HERE, DO YOU?
>> WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION
OR ANY KIND OF INTIMIDATION.
>> HI.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> Reporter: SHE ASKED WE NOT
SHOW HER FACE BECAUSE SHE DID
THIS, WENT RIGHT UP IN THE ARMED
MAN'S FACE.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T TALK.
I TAKE CARE OF BUSINESS.
I GO OUT THERE AND DO WHAT I
HAVE TO DO.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> I PUSH BACK AGAINST THESE
KIND OF PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTIMIDATING VOTERS.
>> HE'S PUTTING THAT IN MY FACE.
I'M SITTING DOWN.
HE'S WITH A GUN STANDING OVER
TOP OF ME.
>> AND I'M STANDING UP AND
PUSHING BACK AGAINST THOSE
PEOPLE AND STANDING UP FOR
EVERYBODY'S RIGHT TO VOTE
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION OR
ANY KIND OF INTIMIDATION.
>> I'M JUST SITTING HERE.
I'M NOT EVEN COMMUNICATING WITH
THEM.
I'M SITTING RIGHT HERE.
>> YOU KNOW, SEEING THAT, YOU
WOULD THINK YOU WERE IN, YOU
KNOW, SOME AUTOCRATIC NATION AND
NOT THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> Reporter: TWO OUTDOOR BALLOT
DROP BOXES IN MARICOPA COUNTY
HAVE BECOME AN ELECTION FLASH
POINT.
AROUND THE CLOCK, SO-CALLED
BALLOT WATCHERS, ARE CAMPED OUT.
LATE SUNDAY NIGHT, WE SAW THIS
GROUP OF WOMEN AT THE SAME DROP
BOX.
>> YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK
TO ANYBODY?
>> Reporter: THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
TALK.
AT ANOTHER DROP BOX IN DOWNTOWN
PHOENIX, THEY'RE PHOTOGRAPHING
VOTERS, AND ALREADY THESE
ACTIONS ARE IMPACTING HOW VOTERS
FEEL.
ACCORDING TO COMPLAINTS FILED
AND REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE LAST WEEK, ONE VOTER
COMPLAINED HE WAS CALLED A MULE.
THAT'S A REFERENCE TO A
CONSPIRACY MOVIE THAT SPREAD
LIES ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SPREAD LIES.
>> Reporter: BILL GATES, A
REPUBLICAN WHO HAS DEFENDED THE
ELECTION PROCESS, TWO YEARS OF
LIES HAVE COME TO THIS.
>> WHY ARE YOU IN CAMOUFLAGE?
HOW IS THAT GOING TO KEEP PEOPLE
FROM SEEING YOU?
YOU'RE IN A PARKING LOT.
WE'RE REALLY LOSING RATIONALITY
AND LOGIC HERE.
>> Reporter: ARIZONA HAS LIVED
THROUGH THE DISCREDITED PARTISAN
REVIEW OF MARICOPA COUNTY'S 2020
BALLOTS.
AND NOW REPUBLICANS ON THE
MIDTERM BALLOT, LIKE
GUBERNATORIAL NOMINEE KARI LAKE,
ARE RAISING DOUBTS ABOUT THIS
NOVEMBER'S ELECTION BEFORE A
SINGLE VOTE HAS EVEN BEEN
COUNTED.
>> I'M AFRAID THAT IT PROBABLY
IS NOT GOING TO BE COMPLETELY
FAIR.
I WISH I COULD SIT HERE AND SAY
I HAVE COMPLETE FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM.
I DON'T HAVE FAITH IN THIS
>> WE BEGIN TO LOOK AT DEFINING
FENCE.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICAN
SECRETARY OF STATE NOMINEE MARK
FINCHEM URGED FOLLOWERS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA TO WATCH ALL DROP
BOXES AND MADE A CONSPIRACY
REFERENCE TO DEMOCRATIC DONOR
GEORGE SOROS.
>> THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
ELECTIONS, TO AVOID THESE SORT
OF CONFRONTATIONS.
IT'S BEEN NORMALIZED IN SOME WAY
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO NORMALIZE
IT HERE IN MARICOPA COUNTY.
I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE, LET'S TAKE
THE TEMPERATURE DOWN.
>> KYUNG LAH JOINS US FROM MESA,
ARIZONA.
I UNDERSTAND THE SHERIFF OF
MARICOPA COUNTY HAS WEIGHED IN
ON THESE INCIDENTS AS WELL.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS THAT
BASICALLY THIS DOESN'T MEET A
THRESHOLD FOR A CRIME.
HE WAS SPECIFICALLY ASKED, WHAT
CAN YOU DO ABOUT THIS?
AND HE SAYS HE'S GOING TO EXPEND
RESOURCES.
I CAN SEE TWO SHERIFFS PATROL
VEHICLES SITTING NEARBY.
THEY ARE KEEPING WATCH ON THIS.
THERE ARE UNDERCOVER DEPUTIES
HERE AS WELL.
BUT THAT THERE IS A RIGHT TO
BEAR ARMS HERE IN ARIZONA, AND
THE TACTICAL GEAR, WHILE HE
CONSIDERS IT VERY UNFORTUNATE,
IT IS CLOTHING OF THEIR
CHOOSING.
AND WHAT IS STILL HAPPENING OUT
HERE, ANDERSON, IS THIS IS THE
BOX OVER MY RIGHT SHOULDER, VERY
INNOCUOUS.
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE VOTE.
BUT THIS IS STILL CONTINUING.
YOU CAN SEE THESE FOLKS ON THESE
LAWN CHAIRS.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR ANY OF THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP IS ARMED.
THAT'S USUALLY WHEN THE SUN
COMES DOWN THAT PEOPLE HERE AND
DEPUTIES HERE HAVE TOLD US THAT
THEY SHOW UP.
THE SHERIFF DID SAY THAT HE'S
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SEE IF ANY OF THIS
MIGHT BE IMPEDING THE VOTE, AND
IF THIS IS A VIOLATION OF A
FEDERAL CRIME.
ONE THING I SHOULD ADD,
ANDERSON, IS THAT A LAWSUIT HAS
BEEN FILED BY A COUPLE OF
ACTIVIST GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS SEEING IF THEY